pour le moment regardez on est donc
casino pourquoi parce que jérémy frérot
jérémy roze les parties des frérots de
la ville de las vegas jeu égal roulettes
égal je voyage place assure le génie
dans tous les casinos il ya une artiste
a cédé à ces millions qui joue au césar
palace spears
non non non non on à isabelle morini
bosc qui va se mettre avec vincent
filiale là bas mais non il va alors qui
va chanter il va sauter comme dans un
casino
par contre quand on fait comme ça vous
pouvez arrêter c'est très simple je vais
vous poser une question et je vais
demander aux téléspectateurs aussi de le
dire ce qu'ils en pensent de réagir sur
twitter bien sûr hashtag est mp je
laisse y
vous savez le royaume uni vous avez le
droit de ne pas jouer c'est très simple
ça suffit qu'est ce qui se passe là bas
tant pis c'est tout le monde parce que
vous le dis aujourd'hui veulent
absolument se venger sur moi donc ils
sont en train de rigoler depuis le début
je les sens agite étude avait ici ils
veulent perdre et des banquiers
prévoient leur non non non non non non
non justement non parce que je les vois
rigoler tous les oeufs
je me demande si vous voulez jouer
contre moi j'ai pas là vous aurez vous
avez personnes droites putsch du
chocolat etc voilà on se cale à te sens
tu es toi les oui oui vous jouez oui
mais pour l'instant oui mais vous jouez
là alors je vais vous dire qu'il joue tu
ne joues pas michèle torr valable tout
le monde peut jouer
seulement je vous explique les règles
vous allez jouer à chaque fois rouge
noir je vais faire tourner la boule
labit cissé rouge vous gagnez si ces
lois vous perdez perçu le 6 mai vous
avez joué chacun votre salaire oui le
salaire du jour est le gagnant on y va
et le gagnant remportera lançant assez
du salaire c'est dégueulasse maxime il a
un salaire tout petit rien qui n'a pas
du tout en saveurs tout petit il a un
salaire
il a un salaire je suis sûr qu'ils
veulent pas jouer je comprends exemple
d'ajouter avec musique
alors non non ils sont par bercy
finalement c'est à du 17 et consultats
les cherry qui joue bien jouer mon match
tu peux jouer tu ne veux pas jouer pour
gérer tuer comme tu laisses à la fois
est-ce que vous jouez au top pilotes
alors voix oui moi je jouais et je
voudrais que switch à la fin et ben oui
à tout le monde joue allégerait alors
atteint alors tout non mais si vous ne
voulez pas jouer ici mais moi j'ai rien
à perdre je peux jouer tout faire
attention mais chéri faites vos jeux
fait beau jeu allez-y côtoieront vous
sur et moi je rien ne va plus faites vos
jeux fait beau johnny m'améliore mais
non mais non
à mon avis vous avez attention c'est
partir de santé au ps rien ne va plus il
vous plait rennes va plus on n'est pas
fait on y va on y va c'est pas candidat
je faisais partie des rouges a stagné
peine que je vous pourrez gagner quoi il
est quoi le salaire les gentils quel
dosage
[Musique]
elle n'est pas agréé ce qui est
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs est bon attention donc vous
pouvez pas demander d'aidé comme ça tout
seul at alors mon macbook l'autre gynéco
ouais
benjamin castaldi et isabelle
morini-bosc vous perdez votre salaire du
jour attention on va repartir et ceux
qui jouent je rappelle à stack tpm
peugeot pourrait gagner aussi l'ensemble
des salaires des chroniqueurs avec le
guen ou peut-être peut-être sous jacente
est parti bonjour olives à dubaï la
photo du real va plus prononcée des jeux
sont faits rien ne va plus il ya tout
rouge avec la boule lyonnaise
et raymond rouge et attention les autres
noirs attention attention à tout parce
que tu as perdu ton est donné
attention voilà
attention est-ce que ça va être où j'ai
ce que ça va être noir attention ça y
est
par conséquent la part des réputés
[Applaudissements]
35 noir un père aimant et passe
attention jean michel mr et raymond
éliminé il reste qu' il reste kenny
belaey qui voulait pas jouer c'est tout
ce qu'ils veulent pas jouer qui m'ont
ils dit attention si on ne sait pas
c'est moi je joue à la royal air france
au dessus de noir n'est toujours avec
les artistique c'est pourquoi j'ai plus
rien à [ __ ] la taille est plus
difficile à éliminer
attention si maxi 1000 francs mono
d'oeil au bout de la piste peut-être
gagné l'on s'en aller mais jeunes
attention c'est parti géraldine tort non
malades auraient été nommé valera
qualifié avant donc c'est géraldine
extra pèse des voleurs alors on arrive à
gagner ce pas qui va gagner deux raisons
gérald épaules
[Applaudissements]
merci à boni palais maximou maxime tu
peux gagner le salaire de tous les
chroniques ce qui est une autre chose tu
peux rajouter mon salaire du jour
également séparant hélène grimaud ils
arrêtent de cosmétiques de la riviera
soir concert toujours un gars comme
maxime c'est très simple tu va choisir
rouge ou noir tu me dis noir chaudier
mer rouge
tu me les rouges se dire et noir
maintenant tout est si tu perds c'est
d'un téléspectateur qui gagnera génial
le salaire de tingwick yacine aubenas
lors des séries si nos toits à nos
consciences à terme du [ __ ] salaires
bas plus le mien aujourd'hui c'est à toi
de jouer
alors tu faut dissiper arrêter là de les
sélectionner allez le le noir le noir
qu'il le doit
donc forcément bah oui le goût
l'heureuse du bio reprendre attention là
on va s'essayer aussi le pensionnat ces
séries ne perd jamais
à zéro tous mais je serais content pour
tout le monde je t assure je joue pour
un téléspectateur je rappelle à chaque
type rpg ou encore vous inscrire est ce
encore quelques secondes et on vous dira
le nom du gagnant dans un instant il
gagnera de salaire peut-être des tous
les chroniqueurs maximaliser noir jamie
rouge
attention attention attention attention
je vous dis savez je viens une chance
sur deux il y à 50%
c'est le chant baisse attendue
relationnel c'est pas de [ __ ] dans ce
récit pas encore demain c'est voilà
c'est passé d'aérologie bien sûr non non
comprenez salaires des chroniqueurs on
va vous donner le nom de celui qui a
gagné dans un instant on attend jusqu'à
mentionner quand ils ont compris s'il a
un bâtard est laissé au hasard